hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to scoot scoot now this game
is cool because the name is cool that's
how life works
you don't even the other justification
besides that I want to play this game
because it's got cool name okay okay so
in this game you're a scooter scooter
River you're a scooter the scooter river
you're a scooter scoot scooty do
scoot scoot in meter Scouten haben
you're a scoot scoot scoot er scoop
anyway I'm assuming you ride a scooter I
literally don't know I think about this
game when I say that I only picked it
because the name was cool
you got damn right I don't know a
goddamn thing about what you're supposed
to be doing but apparently hitting ball
ERDs gives a time penalty go fast
through speed traps for it - oh [ __ ] oh
[Music]
okay okay oh Jesus
Oh God ah [ __ ] shitty tips okay [ __ ] are
these the bollards is that what that's
called it's that close to bollocks I
don't know okay listen
let's just give that another go no I'm
not gonna restart my time I got a
perfectly good god it's whoa holy [ __ ]
oh that's awesome oh it reminds me of
absolute drift oh that's cool
whoops well that wasn't correct before
github all god damnit it's so powerful
okay hang on I'll just swing around and
I'll get I'll get it on the second pass
don't worry about me I got it I got it
love the music Paz [ __ ] okay man I hope
I pass my test speed boost [ __ ] god damn
it oh my father no no poopy dupes okay
round and round and round we go up now
straight apparently luma I'm afraid I'm
scared I'm scared as to what could come
before oh oh oh oh I see what we're
doing here oh oh I see okay well that up
that's another bollard okay no bollard
for me yep it's so there's like no
pressure
oh there is pressure sensitivity oh I'm
just so Hamed fisted that I couldn't
stop hammering down the trigger oh I'm
an idiot oh that's the answer to all my
problems I'm stupid even though I know
now I can't still can't control it
ramp it okay that was less than
anticlimactic alright you're not gonna
trick me I'm the only one to trick me
trick do [ __ ] oh God time oh I gotta go
again I'm gonna do it three times holy
[ __ ] I am gonna die okay here we go all
right nice and slow nice and fast
nice and slow nice and fast [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I tried to stop okay I
didn't try to stop but I tried to not do
that thing by doing absolutely nothing
differently I all I did differently was
start screaming and somehow that didn't
help my problems so I don't know what
the [ __ ] to do okay nice and smooth nice
and smooth
here comes another turn and a foo whew
didn't it the baller that time it's like
I make it that [ __ ] [ __ ] story I
erased all the progress I could have
possibly made with my skill yep well I'm
gonna take an adventurer laughs excuse
me while I hump this whatever the hell
it is yeah boy through the through the
bollards again [ __ ] well apparently I
did it okay we're coming up on the oh
[ __ ] we're coming up on the end of this
lap and we're doing good so far
oh we got to do it again though which is
awfully wonderful and I love it and this
game is going off [ __ ] me come on
ah if I had to get any intelligent
commentary on the game I'd say that it's
it's well made and if I was any sort of
good ha ha god
go around don't mind me I don't know
where I'm going I'm going around
apparently well yes I'll go this way
then oh [ __ ] okay all right okay all
right okay all right okay all right
return to the back what it is what it
does what it is a [ __ ] whoa oh now we
got it well now we got it because I'm
not hammering it down again
ain't that lovely ain't that love early
[ __ ] okay all right okay all right we're
getting better like a shockingly not
even me being facetious but we're
getting better because I got a better
feel for it and more control doing
wonderfully whoa ah [ __ ]
hang on try again whoop nope not quite
well I seem to be stuck oh [ __ ] well
it's an Austen power situation and I'll
get it eventually
maybe not [ __ ] physics-based [ __ ]
god damn it there we go that was my best
laughs how in the [ __ ] 5 minutes and 22
seconds I think the record was like 2
minutes how does anyone do that
huh I'm proud of it alright fine mark
EMU I'm gonna retry it though I'm gonna
do this better okay ready here we go
nice and gentle nice and gentle because
if we can just avoid time penalty oh
[ __ ] Wow [ __ ] me then okay gun it gun it
gun it slew ah
there's a break oh if only I had known
that this this particular vehicle had
brakes attached to it that would have
been wonderful to know I'm like
legitimately concentrating here right
you know at first I was like accepting
my fate as just being terribly bad but
now I'm like I really I really want to
try to do some sort of good I'm not
gonna be world record that's for goddamn
sure but at least I can be markiplier
record which is obviously not any more
of an accomplishment [ __ ] god dammit why
do I keep swinging that wide [ __ ] okay
there we go oh that was smooth that was
smooth all those smooth is my butt Oh
that was less smooth that was less
smooth that was more like my other but
[ __ ] God name forgot Oh get off stop
your proclivity to hum I'm trying to go
for a record here not record number of
content I hate that manner it's [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
god damn them my headphones came off but
I can't fix it because I'm in the middle
of a race I've never done with Kai I
I've never even done worse than this
like when I was doing it before what
happened I came out of such a good oh
[ __ ] whoa okay apparently that's how
that's gonna be okay
311 a vast improvement am i right
okay if I hadn't hit so many cones in
the pan have been so stupid at the time
I want it done better I'm gonna give it
another try I want to give it go [ __ ]
[ __ ] all of them died [ __ ] off with
you yeah alright we got this Oh
goddammit
oh why am I trying why am i tryharding
my eyeballs out oh [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
[ __ ] haha but I am so mad at myself for
even bothering with this why am I trying
to get a good score I did a fine job
last time
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you oh why am I trying
why I want to not do this okay we had a
good laugh good laugh now I'm not
restarting no matter what even if things
get [ __ ] Oh
even if things get horribly fiber
knocked for one I don't know why they
would everything has gone so smoothly
for me in the past oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you dick
no do not come on goddamn it there 2:35
much better I'm not gonna play this
enough to get good to do another thing
so that is the end of scoot scoot for
now in all honesty despite my rage I am
just rat in the cage despite all my rage
this game is fun I actually do enjoy
this lot I can't remember if it cost any
money maybe it was like one of those pay
your own things either way I'll put a
link in the description below if you can
be my high score more power to you I
applaud your efforts you're a shining
star and better than me so take that
home with you so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video I don't know
if that's good or bad but I did it fire
me
[Music]